the perfect build in elden ring to me
isn't one that does like a broken amount
of damage it's not even all about the
fashion
no the best build is one that lets you
beat the game in style for example my
retribution paladin build uses the erd
tree great shield to reflect my own
returning discusses of light back at the
opponent for a third huge burst of
damage
my spiral mage buffs itself with
spinning attacks and then carries those
buffs over to its spell casting where it
becomes a true spell sword and my black
knife build is this assassin with the
optimal stealth and the optimal guard
breaking tools it also uses ashes of war
to spread black flame to enemies
so these three builds are my favorites
and you can skip ahead to them if you'd
like having a unique playstyle is really
important to me and i think i've come up
with about six or seven builds that are
powerful they look good and they play in
interesting ways but i'd love to hear
about your build ideas in the comments i
hope that this video and its comment
section as well can inspire people to
create great characters to experience
any upcoming dlc with
first i want to talk about my
retribution paladin build here's the
fashion and the stats that i run it with
so at the core of this build is the erd
tree great shield which can retaliate
with a bolt of holy damage if you parry
any incoming magic but the truly
incredible thing here is that this
effect can be triggered by your own
spells you can fire bolts from the
shield by throwing triple rings of light
into the ground you can even fire bolts
of light after activating the
slow-moving wraith-calling bell most
projectiles like this can trigger the
effect but the core of this build
combines the great shield with the
discus of light spell
because of the speed at which this
discus casts you can throw two of them
and then as long as you time it right
when the first discus returns you can
just spam the l2 skill to reflect the
second discus as well there's something
so cool about parrying your own spell
boomerangs and with practice you'll be
really well rewarded for learning the
timing i mean
just look at this damage it's insane so
we want to maximize the damage that the
urgery great shield can do now it gets
most of its weapon art damage from
simply upgrading the shield but some of
this holy damage that it does also
scales with faith so it does help to run
a deep faith build with this since your
discus spell will also benefit from deep
faith as well thus we're using the erd
tree seal for maximum scaling the
talismans can also be used to
exponentially increase your shield's
damage the shard of alexander boosts his
weapon art by 15
the sacred scorpion charm increases your
holy damage by another 12 percent i also
like to use the ritual sword talisman to
increase all damage by 10
at max health and the ritual shield
talisman as well to just give me more
defense at maximum health as well and
this means that staying at max health is
actually another cool gameplay loop for
the build and that's where the great
stars great hammer comes in you'll need
30 strength to use the odd tree great
shield already so you might as well use
a heavy strength weapon and great stars
in particular gives you health back
every time you hit an enemy which is a
really nice bonus to help keep your
health topped up at a hundred percent it
also has innate bleed build up and you
can buff it as well i like to run it
with a sacred infusion but you can also
heavy infuse the weapon and use blood
flame blade that's a really good option
to have good weapon arts for the great
stars are ones that hit enemies quickly
because these weapon arts will trigger
the on-hit health regain effect and
they'll trigger any status effects as
well so prelates charge is insane if
it's a smaller enemy that can get
stunned look at your health come back
and just look at the bleed damage it
does
golden land is better for large enemies
and the projectiles it shoots also
trigger the on-hit effects as well and
even prayerful strikes can be spammed to
keep you at maximum health so this has
great synergy with the ritual talismans
as well
for your wondrous physic i recommend the
opaline bubble tier to keep you at max
health and the holy shrouding cracked
tier for yet more holy damage and of
course since you're a faith build you
can also run all of your buffs like
golden vow and flame grant me strength
as well as blessing of the earth tree
which has health regen to help keep your
health topped up because the weapon and
the shield are so heavy our armor is a
little bit light even though it does
look really good
so it's great to have these utility
spells to help keep your defenses high
as for spirit summons with godric's
great rune active i'm able to summon the
dung eater for difficult encounters who
is great at taking aggro while i cast
rings of light and with the intelligence
not crystals here in my physic flask my
intelligence can be brought to 23
allowing me to cast triple rings of
light instead of the regular discus
all in all this build just has a ton of
synergy and i love it
now the build archetype that gave me the
most trouble to theorycraft was the
battle mage archetype i tried so many
ways to blend melee with spell casting
in an interesting way but this is what i
finally landed on this is the spiral
mage and i'm so happy with it um at the
core of the spiral mage are two
talismans the rotten winged sword
insignia and millicent's prosthesis
these two talismans will allow us to
ramp up our character's damage to great
heights for a short period of time so
you get millicent's prosthesis from
killing millicent at any point after she
appears at the windmill heights site of
grace and you get the rotten winged
insignia if you complete her questline
so you can only get one of these per new
game cycle unless you have a friend drop
one for you but if you can't do that you
can replace the rotten winged insignia
with the regular winged insignia which
you can get from stillwater cave in
leonia it's a bit weaker but it still
stacks with millicent's prosthesis and
they basically increase your attack
power for a short time whenever you
rapidly deal damage there are three
tiers to this effect and your attack
power gets higher and higher as you
climb these tiers it usually takes about
three hits to climb one damaged tier and
you need to keep climbing tears to
refresh this bonus or this attack bonus
will drop back down a tier every five
seconds the thorny cracked tier in your
physic flask also adds this effect and
with all of this together you can get up
to 44
extra damage provided you attack fast
enough this attack bonus increases your
staff's attack power too by the way so
all spells will benefit as well all we
need now is a way to attack rapidly and
trigger this effect and that's where the
maurice executioner sword comes in
this weapon art charged preferably can
deal upwards of 6000 damage with one
corkscrew and these talismans it's
really good and that's just with the
weapon's base stats by the way it also
has split magic damage so it does
benefit a bit from any magic boosting
effects like the magic shrouding cracked
tear which you should also be using in
your physic flask but the main reason we
use this sword isn't for its damage it's
to set up that 44 damage bonus for our
spells with a single uncharged l2 you
can climb all three tiers instantly to
the maximum damage tier for your damage
bonus now remember you'll fall one tier
about every five seconds or so and you
will lose the damage boost completely
after about 15 seconds so use this time
to deal as much damage as you can that's
what spell casting is great for and it
becomes even better with this build so
in our left hand is the carrion regal
scepter your best mid combat spell to
cast with this will be carrion slicer
which
is essentially just the main weapon for
any pure cast build it doesn't use much
fp it deals a lot of damage it attacks
fast as long as you're using running
attacks or jumping attacks or you're
using carrying slicer after you attack
with your right hand weapon our cast
speed is pretty slow since our dexterity
is low so comboing carry and slicer is
very important now while carrying slicer
can climb damage tears and maintain your
damage buffs it requires like nine hits
to do this for some reason which is
pretty prohibitive but there is another
great way to maintain your damage buff
and that's with the carrion regal
scepter the carrion regal scepter is the
best staff at high intelligence levels
and the weapon itself has a very very
underrated skill attached to it its
version of spinning weapon is unique
because it has deceptively good range
and it does insane damage it hits
enemies four times quickly so it will
climb you a tier with every three hits
of the staff so weave this spinning
attack into combat to maintain your
damage buff and this weaponize is just
so good that it can kind of be used as
an alternative to the mirais executioner
sword depending on the enemies that
you're facing and because we rely so
much on these two weapon arts this build
also uses the shard of alexander to
boost our weapon our damage by 15
and our final talisman is the great jazz
arsenal and with the scaled set and the
silver tier mask it gives you mid rolls
52 poise and decent defense as well at
just 23 endurance
so my optimal approach to fighting is
something like this first i buff up with
a flask and a golden vowel dagger and if
i have the jump on an enemy then i
charge cast three glint blades now
immediately i initiate with a corkscrew
after that then when the glint blades
finally do fire they gain their attack
bonus mid air from my corkscrew and deal
enormous damage next i two hand my staff
and pivot to carrion slicer which is way
better mid combat and if i have a big
opening then i weave in the spinning
weapon to refresh my attack bonus and
this will make quick work of any
opponent that i face
once the enemies are dead you might want
to attack the next enemy quickly before
your attack bonus falls off and if
they're far away i like to use loretta's
mastery which has perhaps the highest
range of any spell
all in all it's really cool to have a
build like this that can ramp up damage
and it really inspires you to weave all
these abilities together and it keeps
the gameplay feeling really dynamic and
stylish i'll admit you kind of do have
to work for your damage more than most
other builds and it is a very stat
hungry build but with this stat spread
and the silver tear mask as well which
boosts our arcane stat by eight i'm very
happy with how well rounded this build
is for a spirit ash i recommend the
night maiden and swordstress puppets
these match the silver tier mask that i
wear and the build's fashion is just so
on point you even get to see the
gorgeous sword on your back a lot
because you'll be two-handing your staff
and it just looks awesome
i also have a dagger equipped with
golden vow and i carry some boiled crap
so that i can activate one body buff and
one aura buff for difficult encounters
another great way to play is with an
assassin toolkit i like to run this
actually as a deep strength build but i
like to hit 25 faith as well
for some buffs and utility spells at the
core of this build is the mazetti chord
dagger with its extremely high 140
critical modifier according to my
research i think you'll do the most crit
damage with a lightning infusion for dex
builds with this or a fire infusion for
strength builds however i personally
prefer playing with a heavy misery cord
so i can buff it and i'll explain why a
bit later so first let's go over the
talismans of course we're using all the
dagger talismans so your critical damage
is boosted 17 by the dagger talisman and
the cerulean and crimson dagger
talismans give fp and health on both
parts of some critical animations with a
dagger so since we're critting
constantly these talismans will ensure
that your health and fp stay high last
you should use the shard of alexander as
well to gain 15 extra weapon art damage
since this build revolves very heavily
around our ash of war usage now of
course our goal with this build is to
critically strike enemies as much as
possible and to do that we need a way to
maximize our stealth and a way to
maximize posture breaking on our enemies
so for stealth you really can't beat the
black knife assassin chest piece with
just this one armor piece you'll have
this permanent stealth buff on your
character which is way better than
casting a spell or wearing a talisman or
using a weapon art for that same effect
and that stealth effect is really strong
it basically stops you ever needing to
crouch you can run right next to enemies
and still not make a sound
just make sure you don't alter the chest
piece it actually needs the cloak to
work what's also special about this is
that this stealth effect often messes
with enemies that are placed in ambush
which will keep you safe a lot of the
time but the main reason we're using it
is to sneak up on enemies for a crit and
once combat starts you can even opt to
cast the darkness spell and regain
stealth for another crit but once you're
in combat you're gonna need a way to
break enemy stances and keep critting
them so for breaking enemy stances there
are two excellent weapon arts first
flame of the red mains this is so
powerful and it will break the stance of
even the largest enemy or boss in about
two or three casts
another strong option though is the
glint blade phalanx as
each blade does a ton of posture damage
you can get these two weapon arts
individually and use them or you can use
them together i like to set up on a
heavy godskin stitcher with phalanx and
then switch to my meseta chord with
flame of the red mains this lets me
instantly attack with two of the most
posture breaking abilities in the game
instantly staggering any enemy so
individually these abilities can be
spammed pretty effectively but together
the combo is devastating but let's make
this build more unique and interesting
both of these weapon arts can also apply
weapon buffs to the target
the most fun by far to use is the black
flame blade buff this buff applies very
quickly especially if you use it
immediately after an animation like
crouching running or casting a weapon
art so this buff is really fun because
weapon buffs can often be applied by
your weapon art for example with flame
of the red mains black flame will be
applied to anything that gets hit by the
arc of fire with glint blade phalanx the
phalanx will do damage as long as your
black flame buff is active when they get
hit so there's a great animation chain
you can do here where you cast phalanx
then you immediately cast black flame
blade and then the phalanx fires and
applies the black flame debuff to the
enemy just in time the damage of time
effect also applies on both parts of the
critical animation so another
interesting thing you can do is try to
apply this buff before critting your
enemies which is a really fun and high
skill cap thing to try and do blackflame
also just works great with daggers in
general since daggers are great at
applying this damage over time effect to
enemies quickly now i'll admit black
flame blade isn't overpowered it
honestly needs a buff and maybe it will
receive one but fundamentally it is
pretty good and it is a super fun
ability to weave into combat and this by
far is the best way i've found to make
it viable to round out the build i'd
recommend a great shield since we can
easily get the strength and endurance
for it this works great with the godskin
stitcher which has excellent guard
counter and posture breaking
capabilities by itself and is just a
really fun weapon to use
alternatively you can drop some
endurance and run a small or medium
shield with carrion retaliation i like
the magic ice crest shield for its magic
defense and carrying retaliation is just
excellent for countering any sorcery in
general it also has some of the best
parry frames in the game and of course
this build rewards you with health fp
and great damage for landing any parries
for flasks use the stone barb crack tier
for stance breaking and perhaps the
flame shrouding cracked here for extra
fire damage although that second spot is
up to you and of course for spirits
you've got to go with black knife tieche
not only is she one of the strongest
spirits in the game most importantly she
fits the theme of the build
next frostfire builds so if you didn't
know frostbite does a big chunk of
percentage-based damage whenever it
procs on enemies it's almost like a
bleed effect in that way after that
though you can't reapply frostbite and
it wears off in about 30 seconds
unless you remove it yourself so any
fire damage will remove instantly an
applied frostbite effect it won't remove
buildup it'll just remove the applied
frostbite effect which leaves you free
to do that big chunk of frostbite damage
all over again and with the help of
fire's deadly sin removing frostbite is
as simple as standing right next to your
enemies so now all you need to do is
come up with a way to maximize frostbite
build up the fastest way is probably
with hold infused dual twin blades since
i think twin blades have the fastest
status build up attacks in the game with
their unique jumping l1s
since cold weapons scale with
intelligence this is also a good option
if you want to use some sorceries as
well and while they're a little bit
underpowered many of the frost sorceries
naturally have great synergy with this
build in terms of weapons though
anything that attacks fast will be great
with a cold infusion especially if you
dual wield them thus there is a huge
variety of weapons that work with this
build concept
another good tip is to use the royal
remains set with this build this armor
gives automatic health regen if you drop
below 18 health meaning you can't die to
the damage over time effect from fire's
deadly sin if you're using this armor
and since this build primarily deals
damage with frostbite your talisman
slots are all pretty free really
consider a set of powerful defensive
talismans like these
as for a spirit ash i like the skeletal
militiamen to match the whole undead
look that we're going for this next
build is my dragon moth build it focuses
on being as lightly equipped as possible
and dishing out some insane numbers with
jumping attacks
so in alden ring your damage buffs stack
with each other exponentially meaning
your damage will rise exponentially with
the more percentage damage buffs that
you have
and one of the best weapons to take
advantage of that is a fist weapon like
the venomous fang with royal knights
resolve on it this weapon art increases
the damage dealt by your next attack by
80 percent and because it's a
double-handed fist weapon both left and
right hands get this buff
so let's boost the damage of this weapon
to make good use of that the best
scaling for this weapon is probably the
occult scaling the venomous fang
benefits a lot from a high arcane stat
since arcane also increases the scaling
of status buildup and this weapon
applies deadly poison so arcane
increases the base damage and it
increases the buildup of this deadly
poison and when you apply deadly poison
with this build you'll get a 20 attack
boost for 20 seconds from the kindred of
rot talisman
then because the venomous fang does
pierce type damage we can get 30 extra
damage if we hit an enemy while they're
in the middle of an attack animation
this can be boosted further by the spear
talisman which adds another 15
then if your attack is a jumping attack
you'll do 15 extra damage from the claw
talisman and then a further 10
from the chest piece bonus of the
raptors black feathers
but that's not all
at the core of this build is this
talisman the blue dancer's charm which
adds more ar the lighter your character
is and because all we're using is a
light chess piece and a light weapon and
a seal that weighs zero the amount you
gain here is quite respectable just from
this talisman also i should mention that
lighter quipload characters were buffed
in the recent patch and now your light
roll goes significantly further which
makes it an excellent tool now for
getting out of trouble
and of course you can make great use of
that light raw distance because you'll
be casting incantations with this build
as well the dragon communion seal
literally weighs nothing and it scales
with arcane which is your main stat this
means with just a little bit of faith
you can spam faith spells like lightning
spear with incredible scaling and you
can cast golden vow and flame granby
strength for 35
extra damage and some defense as well to
boot you also get access to the dragon
breath attacks with a bit of faith which
also benefit from a lot of your buffs
they even allow you to cast mid-air
while jumping which suits the whole
jumping theme the main attack you'll be
using with this build is of course the
jumping r2 with royal knights resolve
although the running r2 is also a great
option with royal knights resolve as
well as for spirits i like to use the
jellyfish for its poison and its
tankiness and it suits the whole
lightness theme
for flasks i like the oakley and hard
tier for some damage negation and the
cerulean hidden tier to cast dragon
buffs with unlimited fp
overall it's a very fun build and while
your defense is a little bit lacking you
more than make up for it with raw damage
and utility that your buffs can give you
honestly weapons that have the pierce
damage type are just excellent you get
so much extra damage if you hit enemies
on a counter hit mid animation
especially if you're using the spear
talisman and most pierced weapons are
spears or rapiers they're designed to
get counter hits from behind a shield
but what if there was another way to hit
enemies while they were mid attack
introducing the rusted anchor a great
axe that is very unique because it
actually does pierce damage now hitting
enemies mid-attack with a grey tax is
usually a bit of a challenge unless you
tank through their hits and keep on
swinging in order to tank light attacks
in elden ring you need 51 poise in order
to tank heavy attacks you'll need a
hundred and one any poise that doesn't
hit those break points is essentially
useless from a poise point of view
anyway the poise system in elden ring is
kind of badly designed but try to hit
those break points and you should be
able to tank a lot of hits and what the
main core of this build is
is the barbaric raw weapon art this raw
gives you an attack bonus buff of about
10
but most importantly it changes your
charged r2 attacks into a three-hit
combo followed by a slam which also give
you a ton of hyper armor so that you can
tank enemy hits with any r2 regardless
of how much poise you have i think
choosing when to tank enemy hits to
trade with them and deal huge counter
attack damage is a really fun way to
play although you'll want to stack a lot
of defense with this build be sure to
consume boiled crab and cast golden vow
for some quick defense boosts as well as
using the winged tier flask for three
minutes of light rolling despite your
heavy fat rolling build to further boost
your damage with this raw build you have
a lot of options you have the highland
axe on your offhand which you should
carry for a 7.5 extra damage to your raw
buff attacks then you can use the spiked
cracked tier for 15 extra charged attack
damage for talismans you'll want the raw
medallion for 15 extra damage while your
roar is active and you can get 10 extra
from the axe talisman which buffs fully
charged r2 attacks so make sure you do
those and of course we have the spear
talisman for 15 extra damage on counter
hits and since you are tanking a ton of
hits you'll probably want the bull goat
talisman if you need poise or the dragon
crest great shield if you want physical
defense i like to run the octopus head
and the bull goat set because it kind of
fits into that sort of tentacled look
and that ocean theme with the rusted
anchor
and some spirits as well are really good
with the raw type builds
for example red main knight ogre
actually does a special bow attack when
you roar so that's another really cool
thing that you can add to the build
so after months of theory crafting and
testing these are my main builds that
strike that balance between novelty
fashion power and style
i've had a ton of other ideas though but
first before i talk about that i want to
quickly talk about audible
so if you've been watching amazon's
rings of power series on prime video
like i have why not check out other lord
of the rings content on audible as well
new members can try audible free for 30
days just visit audible.com lotr or text
lotr to 500 500. these lord of the rings
audio books they're really well narrated
and i think they're a pretty good way to
fill the gap between episodes if you're
waiting have a listen
three rings for the elven kings
under the sky
seven for the dwarf lords in their halls
of stone
nine for mortal men doomed to die
one for the dark lord on his dark throne
in the land of mordor
where the shadows lie
so again to listen to this audiobook
completely free visit audible.com lotr
or text lotr to 500 500 and get your
free trial started today thank you to
audible for sponsoring this video now
back to the video
so the giant crusher this weapon
actually has the highest guard defense
of any weapon i think at 88 physical
block its guard boost is high as well it
goes all the way up to 63. so what if
you made a build that was based around
blocking but with this weapon while it's
two-handed that would allow you to deal
some truly devastating two-handed guard
counters which very few people do but
this is absolutely the perfect weapon
for it add in the raptor of the mists
weapon art to help you mitigate big
attacks and add some defense talismans
as well some guard counter talismans and
this is a really fun unique and
effective way to use guard counter based
gameplay or another idea so the frozen
needle has a truly unique r2 attack it
lets you shoot a projectile while you're
fainting which means that you could
build this light roll build that kites
enemies with this weapon and backsteps
constantly this projectile from the
weapon can have its attack increased by
the jellyfish shield golden vowel flame
grammy strength but not much else from
my testing meaning it's a really cool
idea but there's just not the talisman
support and the core damage that
supports this build and that's a problem
i ran into a lot while i was
theorycrafting the last few months there
are so so many promising items and
weapons and skills in elden ring that
are just bafflingly terrible especially
the unique things like the frozen needle
this is a game that should be giving you
a ton of diverse ways to play but i have
to say i'm pretty disappointed that
there hasn't been like a developer
effort to buff some of the most
forgotten things in the game like why
are all flails just so bad why do all
the ranged weapons in the game scale so
horribly bows are finally fun to use and
they're just terrible in the late game
no matter what you do pretty much
a lot of consumables are just a waste of
time to craft or use
all of the ghost flame spells are so
stat hungry but they're weak same thing
with the golden order incantations i
tried using a lot of these things in my
first playthrough and i used a flail
build that used ghost flame spells and
it was awful and i didn't know it was
awful i just thought the game was hard
that's my biggest complaint about the
game personally i love it but that's my
biggest piece of feedback for the team
anyway that's my rant over i'm really
happy with the builds i did make though
very proud of the first three and i like
the others as well i hope they're fun
for some of you to take into the dlc or
something and i can't wait to read all
of your comments and your build ideas
below cheers guys
[Music]